Hey Youtube
It's time for me to complain about YouTube, again...I, I, I KNOW..
Can someone just stop YouTube from theirselves?
I feel like YouTube is like a toddler,
Playing with knives and you, let's just take the knife away from that baby.
Stop- stop doing... STOP.
Now if you don't know what I'm talking about, you probably don't know what I'm talking about;
Because it doesn't affect you in any way possible so literally you can click away the video right now.
I MEAN NO!
IT MATTERS DAMMIT!
I don't know if you noticed this. This has been a problem for a very long time:
Number one: YouTube unsubbing you from a channel even though you didn't unsub;
Number two: Videos not appearing for the person you subscribed to.
'member, 'member the Sub Feed?
'member when that was a thing?
This is what we get now we get the Recommended where's the fucking Sub Feed?
Oh it's there........
No one clicks on it.
Now, I used to be subscribed to h3h3 and I was like why am I not seeing their videos.
Well I'm unsubscribed for some reason...
WHY?
A channel that I've actually watched like, regularly why would I be unsubscribed?
And then channels I haven't touched in fucking years I'm still subscribed to.
HOW DOES THAT MAKE ANY FUCKING SENSE?
Now you may have noticed that my channel is dying okay? Let's just get that out of the way.
Okay, my channel is...
It's going down
It's going down hard.
If you're still here you need to get the fuck out
Cuz' it's not going to be pretty from now on.
I'm using reverse psychology.
Please stay I clearly fucking need you.
Well basically, when I was, uh, doing the daily vlogs
I noticed how
Really poorly they performed.
I was really surprised by this
Cause generally vlogs do really well and last year I did them
And uh
They were fine.
But I noticed
Like
Some videos didn't even get two million views.
I know
Didn't even get two million
But that's really bad for me
That's unheard of for me
For the last
Four years, probably
Three, four years
So, for that to happen I must be really doing badly
To my standards
They're pretty high
So I'm like, well I guess people don't like the vlogs.
But it was weird because all the comments were really supportive and really appreciative
But I could tell that people just weren't clicking on them
So I, you know, we started doing this click bait joke
Just to kind of draw people in
"I filmed all day but I got no, I got no interesting title."
"I got hit by my own car."
"Hit by my own car?"
"You gotta get a good frame in!"
"And that's how you make a YouTube video."
And honestly, like, a reason why I
I made this video where I said I'm quitting the vlogs
Part of it was because I thought no one liked them
I thought that people didn't enjoy them and that's why
Uh, and it's already adding all this stress
So I was like, well it's not worth it if, you know, people don't like the content I'm making
We're putting all this effort into it and, and we're too stressed out and too busy
And uh
It was really a, a rough time for me
Now I figured out
It's because YouTube changed
They changed how you view videos
I asked YouTube, respectful
I wrote a really nice polite email
And YouTube said, "Lol, we don't know whats happening."
HMMM
Can someone stop YouTube from themself please
All I want is that the people that subscribe to me
Get to watch my videos
I don't give a shit about whatever else you do
Okay
But that seems like the core foundation of pretty much the most simple
Fucking thing that you need to do
Oh, and don't unsub me from channels that I'm watching
Now what you can do!
You can double subscribe now
Hey, what a great idea
Let's make the subscribtion fucking useful-less
Now they gotta double subscribe
So, uh, hey 49 million people that I collected over, over six years of hard work
Hey, could you do me another favour?
That would be, it would be great
Just click on that little bell there
And then just be like saved
Not on H3's channel
On my, on my channel
Bell me bro!
Welcome, I hope you enjoyed the video
Drop a bell if you liked!
Is that what I'm gonna have to do now?
So what they're doing instead is that they're recommending videos
About people you don't give a shit about
You get recommended whatever the fuck is on the trending tab
Sorry Zoella, but I don't care what's in your bag, okay?
Your subscribers do
I am sure
But keep that shit away from me, okay?
As far away as possible, thank you
I feel like I wanna work at YouTube and just tell them how to do shit
I wanna just be like
Hey
Hey everyone
Stop
Just stop
Just, you can go home
Hey, I got a crazy idea
How about we
How 'bout we just put back the subscriber feed, how 'bout that?
The thing that we had since the beginning, that fucking thing that seems to be working just fine
What I think really is why YouTube is so great
Is the relationship or, Iike, you watch someone on a more personal level
I don't think you guys come back just to watch some Swedish retard for a few minutes
like, maybe, *emotional piano music* you care about me, and you care about what I'm doing
At least that's what I like to think
That is happening at least
But it seems YouTube wants to promote all these random ass fucking videos
That you don't give a shit about
That's what they want to promote instead
Instead of you getting these videos of the persons that you choose to subscribe to and that you really enjoy
Entertainment that you really enjoy consuming
And really what this does, this change does is that
It makes the problem of YouTube having too much clickbait
Get even more clickbait
Because 'Top Five videos' or 'Top Ten videos'
These fuckin' retarded ass videos
Like, videos that have nothing to do with personality
Has nothing to do with content
Just has a really great title and a really great thumbnail
Ten million views and six days ago
It is really upsetting how they did this change
They won't explain what happened, properly, to anyone
It's not just me but a lot of YouTubers are noticing this
And the fact that I
It added just a huge amount of stress when I was already like, filming a show for YouTube
Uhmm
It's really fuckin' sad and really discouraging
I find that a lot of people that work with YouTube
Almost anyone
Have no idea what it is like to work on YouTube
As a content creator
As, ahh, someone who's built this for years and really cared about it
It's, it feels like a kick in the face when they make changes and don't tell anyone about it
'Cause this site means so much to YouTubers
Like me and everyone else, it's not just me
Uhm
It means the world to us
It's something that we worked really, really hard on and I
I don't think they understand
I don't think they will ever get it if you say why this is such a big problem
They never made a YouTube video
They, I don't know, I imagine, like, that a lot of people that I work with on YouTube
They think we're just
Fuckin' record for fifteen minutes and that's it, you know?
It's a lot of work
I know it's like a meme that YouTube isn't a job, or whatever
And in a lot of ways, no it fuckin' isn't
I used to work at a nightclub working night shifts and fuckin'
That was pretty fun actually
But, regardless, I know what it's like to have a shitty job and
YouTube by far, by far, is the hardest job I have ever had and I've ever, ever had
And guaranteed will ever have
Because every successful YouTuber put their heart and soul into this
And we know our channels
We know if something is wrong and if something has changed
I check my videos every single day when I wake up and if something is different and off
I would know about it
The only reason I didn't know about it was because I was so busy when I was in LA
That I couldn't even have time to do anything
I couldn't check these sort of things so I thought it was my fault
And like I said, this is not just affecting me, It's affecting other YouTubers and creators that you care about
YouTube is tryna' kill my channel
It is happening
It's clear if you watch my analytics
It's all going down there and I think my videos are better
I think they're really funny and it seems that you guys enjoy them as well
So it's a shame that it's going in this direction
I'm not gonna let YouTube win
I see how it is, it's because I have so many subscribers
They're tryna kill my channel
This is all a conspiracy!
YouTube wants to kill my channel
It's because I'm always complaining to them
I don't have family friendly content
I clickbait too much, huh, is that it?
It all makes sense
YouTube wants my channel gone
They want someone else on top
Someone really, extremely, cancerous
Like Lilly Sings
I'm white
Can I make that comment? But I do think that's a problem
And I'm not gonna let YouTube win
I'm not gonna let YouTube defeat me
So I've decided
The only way to stop my channel from dying
I know you're gonna think I'm joking right now
But I'm gonna delete my channel
I swear to you
At 50 million subs, when we hit 50 million
A huge landmark coming up
A huge deal, never been done before, no-one's even close
I am deleting my channel
And meanwhile remember to bing that button!
Bing it!
Bing that button!
Do it!
Bing it!
Well, I hope this video had a decent enough purpose
I'm sorry it was a little rambly
I was supposed to shoot something else today
I will delete my channel once Pewdiepie hits 50 million
I think it's gonna be pretty fun, I'm excited to delete my channel
And start fresh
With a new shitty channel probably
I won't quit YouTube, I'll just delete the channel
Leave a like if you enjoyed
Bell me hard and I'll fuck you later